ارتفاع في حالات الاصابه لكنه مصحوب
بارتفاع مماثل في حالات الشفاء صوره رسمه
رسمه خبراء صحيون لمشهد الفيروس المخلوي
التنفسي ار اس في
وفقا للخبراء فان الاصابات السابقه بفيروس
كورونا ومتحوراته ساعدت في تكوين مناعه
جماعيه في مواجهه الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي
جانب ايجابي عكسته العلاقه بين فيروس
كورونا وار اس بي لكن لم تزل التخوفات من
تدايات المرض خاصه مع تسجيل ارتفاع في
دخول المرضى الى مستشفيات الولايات
المتحده
حيث سجل الدخول نحو 80 الف طفل دون سن
الخمس سنوات
ووافقا للمراكز الامريكيه لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها تم تسجيل ما بين
6000020 الف حاله دخول الى المستشفى بين
كبار السن ومن الولايات المتحده الى
المانيا التي دقت ناقوس الخطر بعد ما اصيب
اكثر من سبعه ملايين شخص بامراض الجهاز
التنفسي المختلفه في غضون شهر واحد
وذلك وفقا لمعهد روبرت كوخ الالماني الذي
اشار الى دوري الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي في
ارتفاع معدلات الاصابه ارقام واحصاءات
ترصد بينما تعكف المراكز البحثيه على
تطوير اللقاحات ضد الفيروس المخلوي
التنفسي الذي قد يصيب مرضه اكثر من مره في
موسم واحد والى ذلك الحين ينصح الاطباء
كافه الاجراءات الوقائيه خاصه بعد تحذير
منظمه الصحه العالميه من ان الفيروس
المخلوي التنفسي يعد تهديدا للمستشفيات
علي السمان العربيه